could you use some extra cash in your
wallet today i'm excited to share with
you 12 small changes to small little
tweaks that you can make to save money
on the things that you do every day make
sure you stick to the end because i'm
going to share with you some money
making hacks so that you can save even
more money make money without going to
extreme measures but before we begin if
you like this video please give it a
thumbs up and help support my channel
and if not by all means thumbs it down
but please give me some feedback in the
comments so that i know what to work on
so let's get started number one if
you're like my husband and you just have
to have flavored drinks with your meals
a really simple way to save money is to
swap out your sodas and bottle drinks
for flavoring packets i'm personally not
a big fan of artificial flavorings and
colorings and water is definitely the
cheaper alternative but if you're
already going to drink sodas teas or
juices anyway then this can save you
lots in the summer especially my husband
used to buy cases of sweet tea every
week and we have since replaced them
with these little flavoring packets so
now he can just take a jug of water add
some flavoring to it and for example say
if he were to buy two to three sweet
teas per day let's say four dollars a
day four dollars a day five times a week
for 52 weeks that's 1040.
on a flavored drink and so as we go
through some of these tips and money
making hacks throughout the video just
keep in mind that while some of them may
only like save you a little bit of money
here and there accumulated they can add
up to some major cash number two swap
out your gift bags and tissue paper for
one neutral wrapping paper that you can
use for all occasions all throughout the
year let's just admit it sometimes the
gift bags and tissue paper can cost just
as much as the actual gift and then you
have to go and buy different kinds and
sizes and colors and patterns for
different occasions and different
holidays we bought this neutral wrapping
paper for four dollars and i have since
wrapped several gifts with it but by
contrast i could have purchased this
3.50 bag for a one-time use if you want
to add a personal touch you can use
ribbon yarn a note card or a bow and
chances are you have an empty amazon box
lying around the house that's completely
free so make use of those empty boxes
and save some cash the next time you
need to give a gift number three while
we're on the topic of gifts know your
loved one's love language i really want
to take the time to address gifts
because i feel like when we talk about
saving money we often talk about the
things that you cut back on but when it
comes to physical gifts i feel like
they're important for some people but
not for everybody and i don't think that
you always have to spend money to make
someone feel loved actually you may even
spend hundreds of dollars looking for
the perfect gift for someone only to
find that it didn't have the effect that
you had hoped for a few years ago i read
the life-changing book the five
languages of love and this book taught
me the importance of knowing my love
language how to recognize my love
language and how to spot it in someone
else so why am i even mentioning this
and why is this important i'll give you
an example for the longest time my
husband would make me things he'd spend
hours and hours making me things he's
made me decorative boxes jewelry
furniture and even though i could
recognize those things as sweet and i
saw that his intentions were good i
recognized when i read this book that i
feel most loved when people spend time
with me you see my love language is
quality time i couldn't care less if i
never got a gift in my entire life i
want the thing that cannot be wrapped in
a box time if you've ever gone out and
spent so much time looking for the
perfect gift for someone the perfect
wrapping paper making the bow pristine
and then had the sad realization that it
was a total flop consider their love
language for example if your mom's love
language is acts of service then deep
cleaning her kitchen is going to mean so
much more than a bouquet of roses for
her birthday if your girlfriend lights
up when you spend quality time together
then a walk in the park is going to mean
so much more than a beautiful pair of
earrings or if your friend lights up
when hearing words of affirmation then a
handwritten letter will mean the world
and even if your loved one does feel
most loved when receiving gifts it could
just mean that maybe it would be extra
special if you didn't go the easy route
and buy a gift but instead make them
something that shows that you put forth
some effort so the next time that you
need to give a gift consider that
person's love language and gift them in
their love language it may save you
money and be so much cheaper for you but
i assure you that they're bound to have
a much more positive reaction because
you're speaking to them in the way that
they express love number four if you're
someone that tends to have leftovers
when you go out to eat check out what
the kids meal portions are like at
certain restaurants i remember a few
months back we went to an olive garden
and our daughter got a large plate of
pasta and chicken tenders for a fraction
of the cost of a regular dish but the
portion was definitely enough to where i
thought i would be satiated i mean it
wasn't to where i felt like i'd be full
but definitely enough to satisfy and
some mexican restaurants that we've been
to have served some pretty decent
portions that have left me thinking i
wish i had ordered her meal this is a
kid's meal from a thai restaurant that
we went to and it was significantly
cheaper than our adults meals can i just
say that it looks pretty darn appetizing
just be cautious with this though
because some restaurants may not want
adults to order from the kids meal
because of course they don't make as
much money with this and they don't want
everybody ordering from the kid's meal
so don't tell him yes he sent you
number five this one is totally random
but it's my recent game changer if you
do a lot of cooking and baking at home
then consider swapping out your
disposable oil spray bottle for a
reusable bottle instead and really in
general reusable items save you so much
more money in the long run i actually
have two videos on lots of reusable
items that you can swap out for some big
money savings but this one's just my
most recent swap i was buying these
little disposable bottles at our grocery
store for around three dollars each when
i could have just been buying a big tub
of oil and refilling the bottle when it
runs out i think that our big jug of
olive oil was like 15 or something like
that so i'm really excited that now we
don't ever have to buy the disposables
again and that we can just use this much
cheaper alternative number six while
we're on the topic of food this one is
not one that i currently do but it's one
that i used to do when i worked as a
nurse on night shift and we used to do
this actually weekly and that is to have
potlucks for lunch if you work in an
office area or a place that has a
designated break room or work room a
potluck can be a great way to save some
extra cash because even though you do
spend some money on sharing some food
you're bound to have a variety of
choices and at least for us we always
had enough for our 12-hour shifts and
some take-home food but it really became
a fun way to save money and because we
did it so frequently we had a sign-up
sheet that had the dates that we would
be doing the potluck and who would be
bringing what and so if your job doesn't
have something like this maybe you can
arrange it and it could be a really fun
way to get to know your co-workers and
save some money in the process number
seven also goes to those of you who work
in that sort of environment and is to
consider having a bulletin board where
you can post things that you have for
sale rent trade that sort of thing the
hospital that i used to work at actually
had a weekly fire
fire flyer not a weekly fire they didn't
have a weekly fire they had a weekly
flyer where we could post things that we
were selling or renting and things like
that but we also started in our own
break room a bulletin board i mean just
index cards on a thumbtack where we
could post things and so having the
people that already know you that may
trust you i don't know
is so much easier to sell your things
and convenient too because they may not
be as likely to think that you're trying
to scam them i mean hopefully you're not
scamming your coworkers right
so maybe find out if your job has
something like this or start one
yourself
number eight on to the good stuff the
money making hacks
sell your metal junk i'm not telling you
to store metal junk around your house
but you'd be surprised that some of the
things that you'd pay to go dump you can
actually get paid for recently my
husband started storing old copper from
renovation jobs instead of just tossing
it in the dump and the last check that
we collected from doing this came up to
548.68
from collecting trash if you have metal
that you need to toss before you pay to
toss it find out if you can get paid for
it and the same goes for empty soda cans
and recyclables you'd be surprised how
much you would make on the things that
are already lying around your house
number nine as a home nurse i do a lot
of driving and i don't know about you
but where i live the gas prices have
gone up and if you're like me and you
have no choice but to drive then
consider using the app gas buddy to save
you money on your trips what this app
allows you to do is to search for the
gas stations around your area and be
able to see the prices along your route
so that you can always choose the
cheapest option wherever you're going
and similar to this you can also use an
app that can give you cash back on your
purchases of guests like the upside app
this is actually one that was only just
recently introduced to me by a co-worker
who was also a home nurse in travels a
lot and she says that she's already made
it over a hundred dollars on this so
basically what this does is it gives you
cash back on the purchases of gas that
you're already making but it gives you a
referral link through which you can get
a bonus through people that use that
link but it also gives them a 15 cent
per gallon back on their purchase of
guests so it's a win-win for both
parties it helps you when you purchase
gas if you refer people they make a
bonus and you make a bonus for referring
them so let's say you're like me and you
commute a lot even if you never refer
anybody it can give you some cash back
on something that you're already
purchasing anyway so number 11
piggybacking on this one you can also
use apps that give you cashback on your
grocery purchases such as ibotta or
fetch and the cool thing about these is
that you can stack them and use them
together and they work in a similar way
you basically snap pictures of your
receipts and it gives you cash back on
the purchases that you make and once the
money adds up what you can do is use
them to redeem gift cards to your
favorite restaurants or popular stores
such as amazon or target and like the
upside app it also gives you the
opportunity to make a bonus when you
refer people and they get a bonus as
well and even if you never refer anybody
you're already making these purchases
anyway so why not make some money out of
it i've never tried ibotta i do
personally have fetch and the only two
downsides that i can see with this is
number one that i think it has the
potential for some people to spend more
money than they would normally because
they have lots of promotions all the
time where they give you extra points
for certain purchases and they're all
constantly changing and then the other
reason is that it gives you more money
for popular brands and processed foods
rather than like fresh fruits and
veggies which is most of what i buy so i
don't consider it to be like a
significant money maker for me but hey i
mean it's free money right because i
personally do have fetch and i've used
it for several months i have my referral
link down below but you do not have to
use my link or even use a link at all
you can go directly to the app if you
feel more comfortable with that number
12 i kind of hinted at the beginning of
this video it should come as no surprise
that my single most favorite way to save
money on the daily is to swap out
disposable items for reusable ones
instead because every time you toss that
old dish sponge or napkin in the trash
you're literally tossing your
hard-earned cash in the trash sometimes
reusable items do require a little extra
work for example cloth diapering but
you'd be surprised how much these
reusable alternatives can save you
clutter time and space because you don't
have to buy packs and cases of things so
the amount that you would spend in the
long run can really add up so look
around your home and find the items that
you're disposing of most and try finding
a reusable option for those there are
tons of reusable alternatives out there
and you don't have to go to extremes and
use reusable toilet paper but even just
cutting down on some of the things that
you're disposing of the most can really
go a long way towards cutting down on
your expenses that's it for today's
video those are my 12 simple small and
easy ways to help you save money so that
you can spend it on the things that
matter most to you i thank you so much
for watching and if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up and subscribe
so that you don't miss when i post a new
video and let me know what are your
favorite money saving tips i can't wait
to hear from you in the comments and
i'll see you in the next video bye for
now